started so again thank you for everybody
for showing up today I'm Shawn law I
work here TD Ameritrade this is Ben
Zeitlin from continuum you can always
reach out to us write or to is a PI data
annarbor group either through Twitter or
through the email if you want to reach
either of us again I'd like to
acknowledge several groups obviously
none focus for sponsoring the meetup
group itself t america features a venue
animart spark for a lot of these through
advertising around town and also a huge
stage music goes out to the midas at the
University of Michigan for a sponsoring
the food so it's a delicious food that
we get here for the people who are new
to this meetup group just a couple
important points emergency exists
there's a fictive right down here in the
spirit here and stairs to the right of
the entrance right over here as always
we're soliciting for speakers of your
company or at the university you have
some interesting data successes or data
failures please reach out and tell us
that you'd like to give a talk
eventually I think Ben and I was would
like to hold some sort of like lightning
session so maybe have shorter like ten
five five minute talk so look out for
that or just email us if you think
you're interested and we'll add you to a
list and always we're looking for
sponsors in the future and also please
provide feedback to either been or or I
through the meetup group through Twitter
through an email and also check out our
I guess I get a page so all the talks
are added to our github repo so all the
slides so we'll ask Daniel to hopefully
contribute to that and also we have a
website that spreads gonna bring up also
unless you have like click questions I
try to hold the longest runs until the
end although Daniel has really like sort
of a casual interactive session and also
remember this is a boiled space
so please do clean up after yourself so
plate garbage
really appreciate it as always I'd like
there with the Haggadah code of conduct
I guess mostly for people who are new
and maybe exist six so pod unit is
dedicated to providing a harassment free
meeting experience for everyone
regardless of gender sexual orientation
gender identity and expression
disability physical appearance body size
racial religion we do not tolerate
harassment of being participants in any
form all communication should be
appropriate for a professional audience
including people of many different
backgrounds sexual language and imagery
is not appropriate for any of our meetup
events basically be kind to others do
not install a put-down other attendees
behave professionally and remember that
harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for high data attendees violating these
rules they be obsolete up at the sole
discretion of the meetup organizers so
what really I'm sure everybody will lead
kind here right so thank you all for
making this a welcoming in from the
environment and as we always like to
have is a quick quick and dirty
icebreaker so simply we really want to
build communities and we want people to
at least leave here having met somebody
so everybody think of your favorite
season of the year favorite season turns
them to turn to the one of the people
sitting next to you and tell them your
favorite sees it and why it is your
famous season and don't get to introduce
yourself go eat in a prince
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right we're back we're back hello
all right great hello hello thank you so
another thing that we like to do is
hopefully people will contribute in the
future but we like to sort of point out
so this is not the data science there's
some quirky funky things that we've
observed but maybe you want to put them
out yeah this audience that came into my
seat I think it's like a month or two
old but Google has annotated things like
over two million videos on YouTube with
over 500 labels so you can get a label
for what a boat sounds like on a lake or
a boat on a pond or a boat in the ocean
it's sort of incredible if you ever want
to play with that this other thing that
came up recently is this large self
annotated corpus for sarcasm
known as its arcs this is labeled data
that's based off of Reddit which is a
lot of fun to just sort of sift through
in the /s channel any people are reddit
pins again anybody's ever done NLP
that's probably the single hardest
parlament handling sarcasm Mark Evans is
really challenging to teach a computer
to understand but seems like all of us
seem to understand it intuitively right
oh he did there oh yeah and then Python
was last weekend
was how the opportunity to go Marcus and
I voted and in Daniels it was anybody
else there with it oh okay sorry that we
didn't see PyCon is a great conference
is the general conference for the Python
language it's credibly welcoming it's a
fairly diverse this both web talks data
talks networking talks this talks about
the language itself it's a fantastic
place to be if you ever happy up for me
to go you should definitely do it
and people should submit it's a lot of
fun actually not just to attend that's
also presenting give tutorials give
lightning talks and next year's do think
is going to be in Cleveland Ohio really
let's do it next two years next year's
all of the videos from icon are already
up so this is a link the youtube link to
up to all those yeah and then oh yeah
again a big Sheriff Bill O'Reilly so
they've offered to to give you give us
some free ebooks so you gets down to one
of these but we've added a condition
which is tweet at us if you tweet the PI
data and Arbor handle we will send you
the information that you need to grab
one of your one of these free ebooks
here so Kate science related right so
please do tweet at us or follow us
another note to TD Ameritrade so my team
we're actually hiring so we're looking
for a senior data scientist or senior
software developer if you want to chat
about it feel free to grab me after this
or again to shoot me an email or whatnot
logan also with you for administrator to
maybe a pachyderm administrator two
years has been your whole thing yeah is
there any other announcement from
anybody that's looking to hire feel free
to put your hand up so that we have our
looking okay and then oh yeah just
advertise it for our next event so we
usually try to do these like second week
at the beginning of every month but this
is maybe a one-off so the next one is
with Jennifer Marsden from Microsoft and
she's going to be talking about
interested a dream machine learning and
she's going to be using that infamous or
now famous taggle Titanic data set and
this is on Thursday June 8th same same
time same place but it's going to be two
weeks from now so please sign up and
then what's that I guess is the website
but yeah so I didn't like them need a
page because you have to you have to
join the meetup in order to get access
to it and sometimes I'm I'm not sewn and
I don't it means I started building a
just a github page so if you want to go
to high data in our board up github that
IO
I'll start posting everything over there
it's all all the information so you
don't have to go to meet up to download
a talk or community and as an
alternative
yeah the videos are recorded and once
they get uploaded to the PI data channel
then we'll close the roll income there
as well so you can grab them from there
so I'll flip over and go back I'd like
to introduce Daniel white mask he's from
company called [ __ ] there the states
with different fiscal although you are
remote in Indiana right maybe pachyderm
is hiring we potentially are we're
definitely looking for contributors
okay pachyderm is an open-source data
management data science Product data
pipelining and I look forward to hearing
one so please welcome Jane great well
thank you for see I'm gonna give this
maybe I'm looking what girl awesome are
you guys doing awesome okay so I'm
Daniel white knack I work at pachyderm
like was mentioned I'll talk her a
little bit more about pachyderm later in
the talk but excited to be here excited
to is my first time in Ann Arbor even
though I was reasonably close so excited
to be here and then talk to you guys so
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about machine learning workflows and
machine learning pipelines and some of
the kind of struggles and challenges
that go along with that and then how we
can Billy some ways of overcoming those
both challenges
we'll start out by just kind of
presenting some of those challenges then
I'm going to jump right into a demo of
an example machine learning pipeline as
I know all of you guys are technical
people you're programmers or engineers
or data scientists so you won't really
believe me if I don't show you anything
plus it's a lot more fun so if we're
just going to kind of jump right into
that and then at the end I'll give you
some resources and as was mentioned
these slides will be up so they'll be a
few links at the end don't feel like you
have to have to grab a picture we'll
post those online and you can follow the
exact links sound good
all right perfect so just to get an idea
how many data scientists are in the room
okay impressive how many like data
engineers how many just like Python
programmers okay everybody all right
cool
awesome so as as most of you know I
think a lot of this room are probably
familiar with some machine learning type
of problems workflows and maybe you're
implementing those in your own
organization but there's a few different
challenges that come along with those
sorts of workflows that I think are
pretty consistent throughout throughout
industry so the first one of those I
would say is reproducibility some of you
guys might be familiar with this sort of
thing that's going on this is basically
how my my grad work and academia ended
up after the life year for my file names
were getting like increasingly long like
you know generate teachers good this
time with that other config that I had
yesterday dot high or something like
that so there's this real problem of
like any data science workflow or in a
machine learning workflow you
necessarily have a bunch of different
things you're doing to your cleaning
data you have a bunch of different data
sets you maybe have a bunch of different
plots you have a bunch of different
scripts there's like a lot of different
pieces to the puzzle
so actually tracking and figuring out
like how those are supposed to fit
together
and you know actually being able to
reproduce that is a really hard problem
um so why should we why should we care
about reproducibility anyone have an
idea shout it out yeah so collaboration
is a great first point so um none of us
work on silos so you might have heard
like this term like data science unicorn
or something like that um this this does
not exist in this world so there is no
person in this room or elsewhere who has
all knowledge about all algorithms and
you know techniques that you need to
solve every single business problem and
we all work on these teams we all have
various sets of knowledge so we need to
be able to collaborate well to be able
to both review and critique each other's
work but also incrementally improve on
it right if you want to be a functional
team and if I give you something and
you're not able to even reproduce what
I've done it's very unlikely that you're
going to be able to improve on it or add
to it right
what else so one a time yeah validation
people validation of results with
validation rules another one here time
time
save time okay yeah so like I would say
like the time saving and maybe even the
validation comes back to some points
around like even my own personal
workflow like even setting the
collaboration thing aside if if I'm not
able to understand what I did yesterday
and I'm really forgetful so I already
forgotten what I did yesterday if I'm
not able to come back to that I'm going
to have a very inefficient workflow if
I'm not able to reproduce the exact
things that I've been doing and also
validate those and also validate those
on a team so this might kind of lead
into a third point which I like to say
is compliance and we all are going to
have to deal with this pretty soon if
you're not dealing with it now I don't
know if you guys are aware but there's a
bunch of regulations being passed
specifically in the EU the GTR and other
things that basically says that users
are entitled to an X
nation for algorithmic decisions that we
make using their data which should for
everyone in this room just like
absolutely terrify you but the I mean
when it comes down to it if we're not
able to actually reproduce things that
we've done or validate things that we've
done know what data we process then we
have no chance of being compliant with
those things much less validating things
internally so I think those are all
great points
I also think that you know managing our
workflows is a little bit of an issue
right now in data science and machine
learning we kind of got into this
scenario where I'm able to produce this
really cool sophisticated stuff on my
laptop using these tools and frameworks
that I like but it's really difficult
for me at some point to actually fit
that into a company's infrastructure
right if it just stays on our laptops
then it doesn't produce value but then
like we've got the rest of our
engineering organization that isn't
familiar with all of these tools and
frameworks that were using and there's
cool data engineering people who are
writing these really wicked fast
pipelines and our stuff just really
doesn't fit into that framework and so
like a lot of times there's this
friction between those organizations and
moreover if I if there's that friction
there and I'm not able to deploy myself
if I'm not able to successfully put it
into infrastructure then it's not going
to produce value for a company right
which produces friction with the
business right because they're paying me
money to produce value so this is a
picture from Josh wills who's um I think
he's still head of data platform at
slack and then kind of last it's may be
related to reproducibility but I kind of
think about it a little bit differently
reproducibility you know has to do with
you know maybe a single stage or a
single analysis oh and reproducing what
you've done before or validating what
you've done before but we all know that
the workflows that we're doing are not
single stage workflows right so we've
got this that
that and this the produces that we've
got a training set that builds a model
and the model makes an inference and
then we make some plots and so there's
this other idea that I like to call
provenance or like audit trails which
also is very related to debugging and
maintenance because um at a certain
point like as we're deploying all these
pieces it becomes increasingly hard for
us to say that this piece of data or
this result came from this specific
model which was trained with this
specific data which came from this
specific data source right and things
like that okay any questions comments
about that or I go on maybe you disagree
agree Schneider mark no all right cool
so haven't offended anybody yet so
that's all the like just yammering that
I wanted to do so now we'll actually get
into some fun stuff so what I'm going to
show today is not like the most
groundbreaking of machine learning
algorithms or anything or the next big
deep learning model um but what I'm kind
of intending to show today is that even
in the most simple of machine learning
workflows that we could like distill the
machine learning workflow down and for
the most simple of those workflows that
workflow already exhibits these
challenges and it especially exhibits
these challenges as we as we try to push
it and scale it to to production right
so okay so the scenario that we have is
we're all working part of this you know
really innovative startup it turns out
to be a gardening startup and we know
that our users are gardeners and
gardeners really love to do one thing
and that's like measure their flowers
okay so they like to measure the petals
of their flowers and all this stuff and
moreover they don't really know like
which species of flowers they have so a
really interesting problem that we could
sell it for them is if we could take
those measurements that are making them
the flowers and predict what species of
flowers they correspond to okay so like
all of you guys are familiar with
this problem likely this dataset if you
haven't seen it it basically tells us a
bunch of measurements of flowers so like
different pieces of the flowers and then
a corresponding flower species actually
just like a iris flower species
so what we're wanting to do is we're
wanting to take this data set and train
a model that will be able to predict the
species of these flowers and then as new
measurements come in we're going to want
to utilize that model to make
predictions of the species sound
reasonable okay cool so I'm the first
one to take the crack at this and on our
team and what I say is that I'm going to
create a Python script it takes in this
data set and it trains a model and then
I'm going to output from that script a
persistent version of that model in this
case of a pickle file and maybe a little
bit of metadata about the model that I
train okay and I might want to do this
because I don't want to train the model
every single time new new measurements
come in I want to have a persisted model
that I can utilize when I what I need to
use it okay so then I'm going to have
another Python script that takes in that
model as input and then it takes in
various other sets of attributes and for
each of those sets of attributes
predicts a species of flower so this is
this is my workflow seam okay all right
um so this kind of developed this
workflow it seems like okay to me it
makes sense right and it might make
sense to you guys but really it already
exhibits some some issues that we need
to deal with so first of all we've got a
bunch of different pieces here right and
I have this picture in my mind right but
when I give it to someone to code review
or I give it to someone to work on
really what they see is this right they
see a bunch of Python scripts they see a
bunch of files and referencing this and
referencing that and so really it's not
so obvious what goes into what and what
I intended now obviously documentation
can help a lot here but like this is a
really simple problem as the problem
gets more and more complicated it
becomes increasingly hard for me to
convey in a really you know effective
way what I'm doing in the workflow that
I'm intending okay
also I mean regarding like the workflow
management issue I kind of just like
created a couple of single threaded
Python scripts here right and like we
want our gardening startup to be wildly
successful right so it's unlikely that
I'll be able to just like run these
Python scripts as is on like production
scale data right so I've created
something on my laptop that I kind of
like but I'm now running into this
workflow issue of something's going to
have to change before I before I put it
into production and actually um that
also brings in it kind of feeds the
cycle because most of the time when I'm
thinking about scaling things up I'm
also thinking about doing what I'm
thinking about adding more complication
into my code right so maybe I pull in
something like that or maybe I pull in
something like spark or something like
that regardless I am adding complication
to my code and that necessarily makes it
harder to maintain reproducibility so as
an example I mean we're all like amazing
Python programmers here in the room how
many lines of code do you think the
average Python programmer can write
before they introduce a bug into their
code three two three zero so you guys
are really like the glass half ah
half-empty crowd over here in Ann Arbor
um so it turns out to be about about 20
lines of code or or so so like for every
100 lines of code you know we're
introducing five bugs I think if I if I
did that math right so the the point I'm
trying to make is that like we developed
this simple workflow here as we think
about scaling as we think about dealing
with different issues in production if
we're thinking about making our code
more complicated then we have to realize
that that's going to introduce more
issues around reproducibility so even if
I was able to reproduce my workflow here
I might have trouble as I kind of tried
to scale that up so my my proposal I
what I think would be cool is if we
could take the same single threaded
Python scripts that are nice and simple
and that we like and run run on our
laptop and run them the same way with
the same behavior on a production
cluster in a production pipeline that
also tracks all of our provenance and
allows us to reproduce every single
thing that need every single result that
we produce it enables us to reproduce
that so that's kind of like what I'm
going to show what I'm going to show now
with the goals really being to maintain
like the simplicity here which also
helps us maintain reproducibility it
helps us deal with the time issue of us
like having to rewrite things and and
manage more complicated code and it also
helps us in our tracking in debugging
and maintenance so this is where I'm
going to talk about this open source
framework that I work on called tackler
and this is really like what we're going
after with this with this framework so
pachyderm is a completely open source
project so I'll give the links at the
end but you guys can go there's a nice
beginners tutorial you can download it
all you can run it all you can spin up
everything you know without paying
everything is open and it really has two
pieces so
there's the state of pipelining piece
and there's a data versioning piece so I
think it will probably be easier if I
explain it in the context of our problem
here so this is what that workflow would
look like in in pachyderm so you can
notice that I basically got the same
structure here right and I've actually
got the same types of files but now in
pachyderm each one of these cylinders
each place I have data in this data
pipeline I'm going to version that data
so I'm going to put that data under
version control think of like git for
data so each one of these like if I look
at my training data I can make a number
of commits into that training data set
and all of those changes of how I change
my training data are tracked over time
and I can look back in history at any
point in time throughout history and see
exactly what my training set was similar
for my model each time I train a model
that goes into another repository of
data with version and at any point in
time I can go back and see what was the
version of my model at this point in
time um and that goes for for each place
here then in between the points
connecting these the place where I'm
actually doing processing you can see
that I'm going to run those same scripts
that I had before I'm just going to run
them inside of a inside of a software
container inside of a docker container
so these are just docker containers that
have my my same Python script in it
which means that you know especially if
I test the test and build the docker
container locally it's going to behave
the same way in this pipeline as it did
on my laptop so that also helps with
reproducibility but it also allows us to
do some interesting things with scaling
which all I'll talk about in a little
bit so that's kind of like the
processing and the versioning piece I
guess I should also say like the
processing piece since we're working
with containers this could be Python
right but it could just as well the
Julia or R or whatever language
tensorflow SPARC whatever you want to
um and then like because we have this
versioning plus the pipelining now we
get something really interesting coming
up around provenance and tracking
because now that I have all of these
pieces connected in a pipeline and I
versioning all the pieces of data I can
say that this exact inference came from
this exact version of my model which was
trained by this exact dataset and every
time I update my code every time I
update my data I have a tracked record
of that such that I know exactly what
data produced what data and what
containers were processing that data to
produce the specific pieces of data so I
created something that provides exact
reproducibility and this idea of
provenance are like an audit trail
tracking what went into where and
produce what that kind of makes sense
threw a lot at you there so there
questions yeah so the question was
around if if I have all these things
flowing around and I'm tracking them
let's say I have a specific and correct
me if I'm wrong with the question but
question is if I have a specific piece
of data is there a way to like very
quickly identify all of the different
things that contributed to that data is
that is that the basic question sure
yeah so now I understand better yeah so
the idea is like for instance I have a
specific result let me get a snapshot of
all of the pieces of my pipeline that
that created that that result so I'll
actually show that a little bit later
but again we call this kind of
provenance but you can do like an
inspect on any piece of data anywhere in
this pipeline and it will give you that
exact snapshot of all the other pieces
of the data that contributed to that
data along with this specific
commit IDs similar to like think about
get like the commit IDs of the data is
that contributed to that other questions
if something's changed like attributes
right there
can you footnote White's changed so
right now you you can't and as far as
like a so the question was if I make a
change or I make a commit like in get
there's the idea of a commit message so
you can say like you know I updated this
because blah so right now there's not
although any data that you put in here
is version so what we see people doing
like right now like you see I basically
output some metadata with this model so
you can you can very easily save just
that metadata as as another file in this
version control it's a little bit
awkward as of now I mean I think we get
this question a lot so I think it's in
the feature pipeline of what we're
developing but for right now the
workaround is kind of a metadata yeah
question do you have you run long can
you control when you want to run motors
because if I have that huge data sets
and order of terabytes and if I keep on
adding my training data and if I it's
like paying against my models my costs
will increase exponentially every day or
every week so can I have that hopes to
say do not run the model yeah so the
question was like if you could control
when the model is run like instead of
every time you update the data set maybe
run it only after a certain period of
time or only on certain commits so
there's definitely that functionality by
default we will we will keep this whole
thing and sync whenever you update
anything but that's all configurable as
well you can do things like pause
pipelines and then restart them when you
want or like run jobs one-off or like
just uh just supply certain portions of
a repo like a training data set to a
model so all of those things are
possible yeah cool yeah
without actually playing learning flow
models as you go through so you could
actually optimize it yeah so the
question was if we thought about kind of
applying learning as things we're coming
through here so and maybe like optimized
like what model is is trained so we
definitely thought about that I think
one important distinction here to make
is that we kind of provide this
framework of pipelining and the end this
versioning capability but the code
that's run here is exactly your code so
I'll show you in a minute like that code
running there is the same thing I could
run on my laptop which means that you
can run any sort of logic any sort of
code you want in this pipeline for
example like you could do a completely
distributed hyper parameter search and
then automate in like a reduce step
after that you could automate like the
selection of optimal parameters or
something like that in the output so
really it's up to you what you run in
those stages we don't like make opinions
I guess about how about the processing
that you should run just that it runs in
containers and it inputs and outputs
version data yeah yeah so here each each
of these scripts is running separately
and that's intentional so the question
was if if both of these are running in a
separate container so this kind of a
tool will answer here so similar to like
if it was on my laptop I would have
these two scripts because I don't always
want to retrain my model so these would
definitely be to two different workers
or two different containers running but
for example if you wanted to have a
single docker image with all of your
scripts in it you could run that same
docker image and just execute a
different command in each of these
stages yeah and use agility number of
nodes I think at every stage yes you can
so the question was can you control the
number of workers per stage of the
pipeline so yes and I'll
show that in a little bit so each stage
is individually scalable yeah cool
other questions before we jump in yeah
just if you have three sub training you
also for your producer ability you have
to let you keep track of all the seeds
for random number generators yes it's
really part of your model persistence
yes so that's that's a great point so
the the comment was that in addition to
like if you have some type of
non-deterministic step or randomness as
part of your model you also need to be
tracking the seeds that um that you're
using to - for exact reproducibility so
there's two kind of answers here the
first is like that's totally possible
here and this is again we can version
any data here so if you want to version
your seed here or even have multiple
different seeds that you're working off
of that's totally fine the second point
which i think is more general is i tend
to sometimes get like a little bit of
pushback when I talk about
reproducibility in terms of like people
say you know well like I'm using a model
that's not always going to produce the
same number on the output right because
it's non-deterministic or whatever so I
totally agree in those models are useful
but I think it's we can't we can't get
away that easily with saying that we
don't we can't maintain reproducibility
there at the very least I would suggest
like in most scenarios you can run that
model over and over again right and you
should be able to have a predictable
distribution of results for that model
and so like whatever model you're using
whether it's going to produce the same
number or class or output every single
time or not we as data scientists have a
responsibility to understand what is the
expected behavior of this model because
you know the the things that we're
producing have a pretty big impact at
this point I mean we're producing
applications so that we're expecting
people to make
decisions based on if we don't know the
expected behavior and stuff and kind of
goes south um then and we can explain
what's going on then guess what those
people will never ever trust your model
again like even if you fix it they're
never going to pay attention through it
again
it looks like the first point and the
second point is like I mean the stuff
we're producing now it's pretty the
impact that is having for users is is
more and more right so like if my
self-driving car turns left instead of
right that has some pretty serious
impact right on a user potentially so
yeah yeah exactly so we I mean I I guess
sort of thing is this is kind of like a
total aside but we need to have empathy
for our users and for the people that
are consuming our model and we need to
have like an understanding of what we do
so in this case it might be that you
version that feed so you can exactly
reproducing it might be that you just
you you run an experiment over so you
can run this over and over and then save
the version results and look at that
distribution of results to get your your
expected distribution yeah cool so I
went way off on a tangent there you guys
ready for a demo yeah all right cool so
we'll move over here so I'm just going
to set up I'm going to set up this and
then we're going to kind of see how all
all those things play together and what
I have here is a cluster setup if you
guys are familiar with kubernetes is the
kubernetes cluster if you're not
familiar don't really worry about it
kubernetes is a way to manage
deployments of containers on a multi
node cluster and that's basically what
we're doing here because remember all of
our processing stages are containers but
as far as kubernetes you don't have to
worry too much because you'll be
interacting with with pachyderms so
pachyderm is running on this on this
cluster this is just like the pachyderm
daemon or the service that we're going
to be interacting with so as I'm
interacting with pachyderm all I'm doing
is
um sending requests off to the service
and then it's doing the corresponding
things okay in the way that I'm going to
interact with that is with PAC control
or command line tool so there's also
various ways to do this so there's a
Python client for example that you can
use is a go client we work off of
protobuf so there could be any client
you want and there's a UI kind of in the
works as well but I'll just be using the
command line here I was just listening
to a podcast on the way over here about
like the pronunciation of commands like
this I guess there's also cube cube
control which I call cube control but I
guess also people call cube cuddle and
cube CTL so I'm going to call this PAC
control sorry s that goes against your
pronunciation um but I have so I have a
pachyderm here and one thing I can say
is what what repositories of data
version data do I have in my cluster so
right now I don't have any so remember
each of these kind of pieces is a
version set of data that we call a
repository um so what we need to do to
set up this pipeline to begin with is to
create these two input repos here on the
left hand side this is kind of what's
going to drive the rest of our of our
pipeline okay so first I'm going to
create a repo called training and then
I'm going to create a repo called
attributes and as you might expect now I
have two repos of data or two
collections of version data that don't
have any data in them yes yes we say the
weather does actually see so right here
all that's been created is an entry in
our internal metadata store that says we
have a repo called attributes and we
have a repo call training so that's the
only data that's stored so all of these
versioning semantics are driven by a
metadata store which we use sed it's um
very very
scalable but uh yeah that's basically
what we're doing here and that's also
what we'll track like the commit ID then
what jobs have been run and that sort of
thing yeah so basically this is just
saying I have an empty folder I have an
empty collection of data yeah
so now we let's actually put some data
in there so I have this iris data set
which I'm sure you guys are familiar
with so again we have these measurements
of the flowers and the corresponding
species and what I'm going to do is say
put this file into the training repo
that I just created on the master branch
so think again like kind of like get
like semantics you can have different
branches of your data and I'm going to
put a file that is iris so now if I look
at my repos now I have data in this
training repo and if I look at what
files I have I can see that I have iris
so now this is now this data is on the
cluster and this is the version data
that my pipeline is going to be
interacting with we're going to see what
this will create so that was for like
you can also here I just put one file
you can also open a commit and then make
a bunch of changes and then close the
commit so - she just says do that all at
once because I'm only doing one thing so
open the commit put the file close to
commit yeah other questions you can
recursively do it you can yeah we'll do
that in a second so actually here I've
just shown like you can put a normal
file there's like a bunch of different
iterations and combinations of this so
you can put files recursively you can
put files from an s3 bucket you can put
files from a URL so like a web scraper
sort of thing you can put files from a
list of files there's like a bunch of
different ways and of course you can do
it all with the Python client or other
ways to if you want your flag stackable
if you - yes um I don't think so at the
moment um that's a great question
I don't think so so sorry the question
was if you could combine the flags like
- CF instead of two separate flag but
yeah I don't I don't think so at the
moment alright so now we have we have
these two version sets of data and I put
my data into this training repo now
let's actually do this this processing
piece so let's build out this part of
our pipeline so I'll just show you see I
think it's cool um no that's just I just
simplified my prompt for demo so it's
really short yeah
so here yeah the question was if that
was the pachyderm prompt but this is
just a normal terminal um so here is the
the training script that we have if you
notice here I'm not importing anything
special I'm not saying like import
pachyderm or something I'm just
importing my normal stuff so this is the
same way I would run it on my laptop I'm
taking an input directory which has my
training file and I'm saying write out
the model to an output directory and
then I'm doing my training here and then
exporting some some metadata about the
model so here this is just a script like
a normal script you'd run on your laptop
the only thing that I've done is I put
it in a docker container so you could
use like standard docker container here
I made it a little bit special just to
make it really small but I'm just adding
the same the same script here and then
to create so now let's create so I have
the strips I have it in a container to
create this part of our pipeline all we
need to do is supply pachyderm with a
JSON file that tells it how to process
that in that pipeline so this might look
a little bit complicated but
old saying is create a pipeline stage
called model and in that stage run this
docker container which I'll actually
change before I forget because I just
showed the SVM model and then when you
run that container run this command in
that container so this gets back to the
question earlier you can definitely have
the same container and run different
commands so here I'm just saying run my
run my training script and the only
other thing I'm saying is run it on that
training input repo so I have like the
model how to run it and what to run it
on yeah sure yeah so like um how many of
you are familiar with like a BM right or
VirtualBox so a docker container you it
kind of almost feels like that but it's
not quite the same so with a vm you
actually have like a guest you know you
have an OS running inside of the VM and
you also generally have to specify what
resources that VM is going to take up so
a docker container you can see like with
this docker file here so with this
docker file I'm kind of installing a
bunch of stuff in this image and then
adding my scripts so it kind of almost
feels like I'm working in Ubuntu but
it's actually in the docker container
when it spins up there's not an actual
OS running in there so all of these
containers are sharing the resources of
the underlying Linux kernel that they're
running on so when you spin up a docker
container all docker containers running
on that node will share the same
resources of the underlying kernel and
they're also as a result of not having
to have that or less in them just like a
file system and your libraries and
dependencies they're much smaller so
like this docker container I think was
about like 80 megabytes if you're
looking at like a virtual machine or
other things you're looking at many
Digga bytes right so it makes it a lot
more portable
as well yeah yeah just to interject to
see the face your level a doctor
container is almost like a like an onion
it's built on layers so you say I want
to build off of you blue - I want to
have - three lifts on all those
dependencies within the docker container
that way when somebody uses that
container later on they don't have to
worry about tracking down your
dependence so furthermore helps
reproducibility later off yeah so if I
run this docker container like I have
docker running locally if I run that
docker container locally and then I run
it on a server in AWS that's running
docker if will literally run the exact
same way in both of those environments
there's absolutely no change so how does
it ensure that it produces all the same
resources so remember it it shares the
underlying resources so like if my if I
spin up a service let's say and then
it's just sitting there lazily not not
doing anything it won't be sucking up
resources except what to take what it's
taking to spin up that docker container
which is very very minimal and then as I
receive load into that it will utilize
the underlying resources of the
underlying node so one of my wizards
entre container from your look from your
laptop to an AWS huh server how do you
how's it going to reconcile the
differences between whatever resources
may or may not be available on this
server
different versions of libraries so all
of that is in it so that is the question
was how is it going to reconcile
dependency so um all of that is inside
of your container so so like was
mentioned you can say like run this with
an Ubuntu filesystem and all of these
dependencies and you can say Ubuntu
14.04 16 whatever and install those and
it'll just be exactly like it's running
on Ubuntu except underlying it's a
docker engine that's running on the on
the Linux kernel of the host so all of
that all of that mapping to actual
resources is handled by the docker
engine which is what's running these
docker can take
your share I can't see the difference
right now between then VM but I'll go
home agree yeah I would look up if you
just search online for like dr. can
docker image versus VM there's a nice
picture um that shows us the biggest
difference is that there's that lack of
actually the full OS running and the
only container gun yep cool so yeah
again
so we're saying in this pipeline stage
so we're going to create this pipeline
stage model we're going to use this
docker container and run this command in
there which is literally just the same
script that I just showed you and we're
going to run it on that training data
and those other little pieces I'll
discuss you know I'm shortly so then to
create this I just say create pipeline
and I supply it that JSON file and now
actually something interesting has
happened it's actually went ahead and
spun up a job to do that processing so
the reason for that is that pachyderm
said you have told me remember this is
this is kind of like declarative it's
like you have told me that there is a
model pipeline stage that's supposed to
process training data and you've
committed training data that hasn't been
processed yet so I'm going to go ahead
and make happen what you told me to
happen make happen and run this pipeline
train the model and output the result
okay
which hopefully is done by now okay
success the other thing that's happened
here is now if I look at my repos I've
actually got one more okay so also Pat
what pachyderm did is it says I'm going
to process this data in my pipeline
stage but then I'm also going to output
data so I'm going to create another
version collection of data that
corresponds to the version data that's
output from this pipeline stage okay yep
that's or
attention right so I have an aspiring
responsibility to make sure that the
data that I put it to one commits itself
so that the the question was since is
doing this for every commit then you're
responsible for ensuring that the data
committed in each commit is is self
consistent so yes and no so there's
various ways to configure this but for
example similar to like if you're
feeding data into your application
running anywhere if you supply a wrong
format or corrupt data or a lack of data
or whatever it is then the pipeline will
fail like you can get all those logs and
that standard thing will happen but one
nice kind of thing that isn't the same
as that case is like you can specify
what I'll show here in a second of like
how to process data in that version repo
so in this case we always need all of
our training data to make our model
which is a lot of the case with training
models but let's say I was doing edge
detection on images I could put in a
million images process all those output
the corresponding output if I add one
more image the I only need to expose
that one image to my processing step
because all the other ones have already
been processed and they're totally
independent
so pachyderm is different it is just
supply that new data to the processing
step and of course again this is
completely configurable because that
that wouldn't work so well in in this
case right with the training case yes
how it knows what our model is yes and
so so that was actually great question
so the question was how does it know
what is output from the model so if you
look here in this pipeline spec remember
I take in an argument for my input
directory and an argument for my output
directory if I was running this locally
this might be like slash temp slash I
a social thing but here I'm using
specific directories so when the
container comes up and it's processing
data pachyderm will automatically mount
that data and the container at /p FF /
training then correspondingly whatever
you put into the /p FS / out that's
what's going to be version in the output
so pet /v FS / out is kind of this
magical directory that is like all your
output this isn't just naming convention
yeah so this is the /p FS is just
convention but yeah it's just like
working with other any other file system
so like you take files and you write
files out yeah oh I was a bit confused
many looking to get what they call if
you have split data and they fit the
same training data into multiple pieces
in the run it across yeah so the
question was how exactly this splitting
of data will happen so we'll get to that
very soon so I'll defer your question
for a moment but I'll show you very
quickly yeah so you mentioned room where
data is different where yes how you show
the CSV how does it handle the kleiner
II of like JPEGs
yeah yeah so um one distinction here is
that we so we content address and hash
your files but the versioning happens at
the file level so if you really want to
if you really want to dislike lines or
JSON blobs for example you can totally
do that we have a flag that's just like
up - - split and it will underlying it
will split that into multiple different
pieces of version data by default it
will just diff on the on the full file
in the case of like the images that
would mean like if you committed you
could commit the same image over and
over again and nothing would change like
the image wouldn't be copied like
nothing nothing would change or be
triggered as soon as you commit any
change to that that image
then like we would track that as a
change or an update but we wouldn't like
like this within that file
yeah other questions yeah so the
question was is there a way to show the
version history so I'll get to that in
just a moment yeah so I'll also defer
that one but let me know if I don't hit
both of those points okay so we have
this we are kind of at a point where we
trained our model that model is there we
can also verify that the files got put
there so there's my my model files that
I expected now let's let's just create
this next bit of the pipeline and then
I'll get into some of those those other
questions so the next piece of the
pipeline is is very similar so again I
have a simple Python script basically
the same taking command-line arguments
for the directories here the only
differences I'm just like whatever files
are in here I'm just walking over them
and for each of the attribute files I'm
doing an inference and then outputting
the results okay and then I have another
corresponding
file for this inference stage again just
this is my stage this is what I'm going
to run the main difference here is that
is that I have two inputs and I'll get
back to these globs here in a second
which is related to your question but
here just think of like I have two
inputs one model one attributes that's
how I'm going to process the inference
okay so let's go ahead and create that
pipeline
okay but I still only run one job so why
do I still only have one job
why didn't I automatically start process
doing inferences yeah exactly so I've
created this collection of data right
but what pachyderm is saying okay I know
that I'm supposed to run inference you
just haven't given me any data yet to do
inference on right so it hasn't it
hasn't launched anything so let's go
ahead and do that I just have a couple
of test files here so these just have
different sets of attributes in them and
this time I'm going to put them
recursively as I mentioned before let's
just that extra flag I'm going to put
all those files in there now I have data
in in there and if I look I've spun up
another job and it's actually already
completed so it now said now you've
given me inference data now I need to
make inferences and likewise it's also
created an output repo for inference of
the same name if I look at what files
are in there I've got two corresponding
to each of those files that I put in and
I can get those we get the second one
and there's my my species so we've we've
now created all these version pieces of
data we set up our entire pipeline such
that now anytime we update any of these
pieces of data we're going to
automatically trigger an update of
everything else so this is like a
pipeline that keeps itself in sync with
changes to data or changes to code but
now let's actually dig into these kind
of two questions that came up one around
scaling and one around the actual
provenance that I mentioned yeah joint
so like you me do like a union of the
data or something yeah so you can
totally
if you wanted to create like say another
like a plotting or something you could
totally take the input of both of these
and just like process that in another
stage you can just or if you just want
to get the data you can use like the
command line tool like I did but there's
also like I said the Python like if you
wanted to spin up a jupiter notebook and
get both of those pieces and do it
interactively you could use the Python
client to pull on both of those pieces
real quick yeah the docker containers
yeah so that's a great question the
question was if the docker containers
themselves were version so yeah so
there's a registry in the cluster that's
maintaining those images now you can so
it is possible to shoot yourself in the
foot here because if you specify like in
that image like if I specified like
latest
that's always going to like overwrite
the latest image so change the change
this yeah so so you can you can
definitely do that but it's not it's not
best practice so we actually provide a
convenient way which I'm not going to
show here but I can totally point you to
we have an update feature where if
you're updating like if you're making
changes and you specify a flag it will
automatically tag a unique version of
that image that's tracked with your with
your specific processing so that's the
way to do it now you can totally like
avoid that and use latest and you'll run
into the issue that you just mentioned
so there's still like that best practice
there but the functionality is provided
yeah okay so let's address like the
scaling thing first so now like let's
bring it back home where our gardening
started off and we've got this cool
pipeline built and now we're like really
growing and we've got like tons of these
attributes coming in right now remember
this is like my single threaded Python
script and really I would like to keep
it as simple as it is but now I need to
scale up this stage of my data
processing so what I what I can do
actually is
go back here and go down to this
parallelism spec okay
and you can see that there's here I've
just set this to a constant of one that
means it's only going to spin up one
worker to do that processing but I could
just as well easily change this to ten
right
oops ten and what's going to happen is
this gets back to like how you're
splitting the data so you can see I've
kind of specified this glob pattern here
so this is similar to like what you
would use on the command line this is
saying that you can pack it or you can
split the data based on everything
that's in the root of that repository so
all files that are in the root of that
repository whereas here if you look at
the model I just have slash and that
means like every time you process you
need all of that data because you need
all of that that model so this is how
pachyderm knows which data it can split
across and this is really flexible
because you can split across specific
directories a bunch of different
directories a bunch of different files
specific directories within a repo
there's a bunch of different ways to
split your data and you can also like
here specifies cross there's different
ways you can join your data to cross
Union or just like individual repos and
we can talk about that after - if you if
you're more interested yeah so it's
actually the question was if I'm
spitting out different Python processes
so I'll show you in a second when I
update this but it's actually going to
spin up a bunch of different containers
so think about like in like a dozen new
world the way you do distributed
processing is you distribute across
these like Java scholar mapper and
reducer classes that's the unit of data
processing here the unit of data
processing is a container so like when
you're splitting up your work across
this you're spinning up multiple
containers where each one of them is
running that same script yeah
No yeah so actually this is under the
hood this was running on a single node
cluster so you can see a spin out
multiple now obviously like you can only
do so much
with the nodes that you have so you know
generally it doesn't do you much good to
spin up like more containers than your
number of nodes times the number of
cores but you know yeah cool so let's
see if I can do this so I've changed
that now now if I do PAC control update
pipeline infer and then I look at my
cluster it's actually spinning up all of
those different workers and if you don't
know anything about kubernetes like
don't don't worry about it but there's
actually some cool stuff here these are
being created as replica sets which
means that this cluster is self-healing
so if I lose a node kubernetes will
automatically reschedule the state of
all of my workers across the other nodes
in the cluster and kind of self-healing
that way as well as if I auto scale my
cluster it will reschedule those
resources across the new nodes so this
is actually pretty uh pretty nice under
the hood you can scale down the AMA
dynamically um yeah so here like you can
hear over progress yeah I mean you saw
that like when I um so when I spun up
the new workers it actually terminated
the old worker because it didn't know if
I wanted the the same worker instance or
new ones but if you have a job running
and that fails as a result of you doing
some scaling kubernetes will
automatically reschedule that as well so
I did that the other question was around
provenance so this will be the last
thing I'll do it won't catch you guys
any longer but I have a very similar
image so the image is the same it's just
I'm using Lda and
instead of SVM for my training so if I
update my model okay um so something
pretty neat happens here if I can type
in time so it actually it's going to
spin up a new sorry it's hard to see
with the wrapping but it's spun up a new
job because now I have a new type of
model that I need to train and my
results weren't in sync with that my
version model wasn't in sync with that
so pachyderm automatically updated my
model then as soon as that model was
retrained pachyderm nude that there was
a new version model so it updated my
inference as a result as well so the
data here updated and then pachyderm
said oh now the data here is updated I
need to rerun this yeah yeah so that the
two separate entities are like so the
question was how do we distinguish
between the different entities like
inference and inference so there's
there's always um so these are pipelines
and repos so each pipeline has a
corresponding repo of the same name so
that's that's by convention but you can
you can definitely like purify list
pipeline oops I can see that I have two
of those running and their names and I
can also see their corresponding oops
their corresponding repos if I list the
repo now here's the kind of like secret
sauce I guess I'm not that it's secret
it's open-source but if I look remember
I've kind of run a few different jobs
here and now I get into a situation
where I'm like oh well what model
created what inference
change my model right so I can go here
and say well this inference that got
created let me inspect that one so if I
inspect that specific commit this kind
of comes back to the state of the
pipeline at a certain point this will
tell me that this was the exact state of
my training data that trained this exact
model wherever it is this exact model
and that model took in these exact
attributes to produce that exact
inference and so if I wanted to see what
model that was I could say you know get
that one it turns out that was my LD a
model that was just a little bit of
metadata that I output with it whereas
if I look at the other one remember all
of this versions or all of this data is
version right so I can go back and see
what my model was at a previous time so
if I go back to let's say this inference
oops and I expect that commit then you
can see there was a different model
right and if I look at what that model
was that was my SVM model right so I
have the complete tracking over that I
could also get the training data that we
use in each case if I updated that and
this is kind of how you can track things
through
you can either track them backwards kind
of like I did or you can like go to a
specific piece of data and say what were
all the other pieces of data downstream
that were affected by this particular
piece of data we've got the Python
script itself and I didn't see that but
you could modify your training script or
your inference engine yeah definitely so
the the question was around what about
the what about the scripts themselves so
here we are under the hood at least you
should be versioning your docker
containers and we provide that kind of
what was mentioned before this tagging
for the containers and then a layer
below that you should still be
versioning your code and github that
that kind of like still goes along with
this but if you wanted to know exactly
what was run like I can inspect the
pipeline let's say inference and see
exactly what my transform was how many
times it's run all of that good stuff
and I should say too that I'm doing
everything on the command line here but
like two weeks ago we released the first
version of a UI so it's still a little
bit rough but that's also open and it's
like keep Gabriel who's working on it is
doing an amazing job
it's like progressing very fast so um
you can also spin up with this and see
like a connected dag of everything
that's run and what files you have and
what commits have been made and things
as they change and that sort of thing
yes this is really we go back and look
at each one are you it's really some
long mating process you'll do that or do
you have to use your shell so right now
so I've demonstrated with the shell you
can definitely program programmatically
do it with the Python client but again
like the other way right now would be
like with this UI that's coming out and
and that will allow you to very quickly
like click through and see what has
changed where yeah keep in your pipeline
picture again yeah sure so now I guess
we're here from one is what I get one of
the cool things is you could you could
do your training your model and your
model output and do your inference or
whatever just like you normally did but
if you change something in your
attributes file only infants will run
not the entire yes yeah correct so
remember that like pachyderm is so the
question was like around what will run
if you change certain pieces so
pachyderm is keeping all these it's like
declarative packet of keeping all of
this in sync if I change this here
pachyderm nose like this is already up
to sync none of this has changed up here
I
need to rerun my inference to create new
results similar like if you changed your
training here it would rerun kind of all
of this so it's aware of what what needs
to be run yeah yeah right so a little
bit simpler mala doesn't have you all
creating the bottle reading but are you
able to accommodate different models
yeah definitely so the question was if
you have different types of workflows or
different models like does that how does
that fit in so this that's actually a
perfect segue so and also related to one
of the questions from earlier um we
don't we make no opinion about what you
run here or the structure of your
pipeline just that you're running things
in containers those are connected to
version data so and remember it's all
language and framework agnostic so
here's our model right now like here I
want to run another thing like you said
that takes in these two things and with
our it creates some plots right so I can
do that and then if I want to do some
like pre-processing of my data and Julia
I just take in that and do that for my
training and if for some reason I want
to do some like pre-processing with a
bash command here I can do that like
this could be tensorflow
or it could be a bash command right we
really don't care and then as things
scale you're totally free to scale up
and down these workers individually as
you see as you see fit yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the question was is there a way
to kind of have this like diff view of
your different models or your files or
that sort of thing so there's kind of
two answers to this the first one is
sort of no and for a good reason because
in insert certain get like semantics
pull through here like committing and
repos and branches but certain things
don't particularly it is
you literally like merging and this
because if you're thinking about merging
like petabytes of data
no human can resolve those merge
conflicts right so that doesn't like
really carry through now with that being
said like if you wanted to like process
based on disks between like two
different commits of a repo that's
something that you can definitely do
we're working on a little bit easier way
to facilitate that now so like I showed
the different ways to put in your input
there's going to be another one this
like I don't know what it's going to be
they're working on it like diff or
something where you can actually build
up different commits of your data and
process between the different states of
them so that's that's definitely coming
as far as like UI or clearly seeing that
not not really at the moment yeah
standard pipeline creates thousands of
plots you don't want to do get file gif
file get file and I'm sure you can do it
recursively but can you do a repo dump
local or keep out the repo yeah so the
question was if if you have like a bunch
of files and you want to get them all
like is there a simpler way to do that
rather than get file gif file um so you
can like you said you can do it
recursively you can also do it via the
clients so like programmatically you can
get all the files right or you can get
like a directory and that sort of thing
we also provide like for development
purposes like a way to mount the
distributed file system locally so you
could actually browse it like mount the
distributed remote file system locally
explore it pull things in and that sort
of thing it's not really good to use in
like for production purposes because
it's like sometimes craps out but but
it's definitely useful for that sort of
exploration yeah other questions aside
from the work football insertion
applause I think I didn't easily using
just pure get versus conversion my data
model codes in the circle
so so the question was like why wouldn't
we use just pure get and version our
data and our code and everything
together so I would say like two pieces
so the first piece is like if you're
using github for example you're not
going to be able to store store in
version large data sets it's just not
possible and nor is it space efficient
because actually under the hood get
isn't space efficient with making copies
and that sort of thing of this size of
data
pachyderm uses its own logic under the
hood to be space efficient so that's the
first case the second piece is like you
conversion everything together and
you'll see a lot of solutions these days
where like there's project templates or
there's like things that version all of
your code and data together but it
doesn't really solve this
reproducibility problem right because I
as your colleague could clone your repo
and put things together totally
differently and produce different
results right so it of course is aided
by documentation and all that but it
doesn't like rigorously define how
things were run and also like for
example like if you're running things in
production and you commit corrupt data
or something it doesn't give you a
mechanism for tracking back exactly what
commit was corrupt or reverting or
overwriting bad data or seeing exactly
what the produce was so I think we have
time for a couple more questions I'll
just put up this slide so all of this
code and the pipelines are online check
out the packet of Docs you can spin this
up locally in like 10 minutes it works
we have a public slack channel that you
can join to ask questions and that sort
of thing this is me and you know we're
open source community so reach out any
time with questions everything I don't
know if we have time for more questions
or I just wanted to take the opportunity
to at least thank Daniel
making the drive up here for having the
courage to live code that's always
tricky thing and yes we have a little
bit of time for questions so what if
somebody wants to contribute so the
question was I'll get your insight so it
the question was if somebody wants to
contribute so you can go to our Doc's
here also on our website on pachyderm IO
at links to our github it's just
pachyderm slash pachyderm and there's
like a little blurb on there about
contributing all you have to do is like
find the ways that the contributor
agreement or whatever it's all apache2
and as soon as you can do that you can
submit pull requests and merge them and
everything so yeah appreciate that and
if anybody wants to work on the Python
client - there's definitely things to do
there so yeah question so science
reproducibility Esben h4y and there are
a number of similar project do you know
similar things or general galaxies was
pre used in bioinformatics this cold
water pipeline I'm not true cinema
further Network yeah yeah so that thing
is very similar I'm trying to see what
what the advantages postpone or reverse
for our practice because like I think
it's very conceptual is similar and them
again because you were coming up do we
and all that or you can have your
everything is the module and then you
can i really like method by science or
your pipeline becomes a worker a lot of
five five and you can do like lorry
allows you to do for example your on
your are a pipeline then you come with
an if statement and additional other one
branch another branch and there was per
message and all five levels underneath
and that's of course if you feel do is
probably either like data commands and
you can go back and then that a magical
manages of how many workers you and I
you didn't mention but maybe let's let
us answer that what is they banded part
yeah yeah so like generally um yeah and
it's again the question was kind of like
there's a lot of other
pipelining and in some cases versioning
sort of systems out there I would say
like in industry there's there's like
outside of science there's things like
Luigi and airflow and then there's like
projects like Anthony and the dot
project that do like data versioning
then in science like you were saying is
I think those are vatos and you know
there's I know there's Sai pipe and like
the one you mentioned I forget the exact
name there's a bunch of these kind of
workflows especially in bioinformatics
the the main things that I think like
I've seen differentiating and each
project kind of has a different flavor
but I think this project one of the
things that it's really focused on and I
think one of the distinguishing features
is this ecosystem of tools that it's
built on so being docker eyes not that
they're not other docker eyes ones out
there its language and framework
agnostic which many are not so there's a
couple out there that are docker eyes
but then on top of that being able to
write on on kubernetes provides a really
really high level of scalability and
like availability and just general
maintenance for your entire cluster
especially in collaborative large
collaborative environments I mean this
is really like kubernetes is built for
Google scale planet scale self-healing
scheduled workflows so I think like
being being taking advantage of those
api's provides a lot of power in this
sort of environment of being kind of
that data layer on top of kubernetes
other ones like airflow and Luigi
they're kind of tied to specific
languages in some way and or lack this
like data versioning strict data
versioning and provenance piece and
other projects that actually version
data kind of lack the pipelining peaks
where this is kind of all unified yeah
so also the question I have is they when
you have lots of data a lot of hanging
transfer data to run a particular script
how does our control take care of a
desert-like
in the pipeline does it who's the data
with your model scripts
Oh The Adjustment into a different
container so the question was kind of
basically getting at where the data
lives and we're kind of how it shimmed
in so behind all of this so we write on
kubernetes for the one piece the data
piece is actually backed by any object
store so that could be s3 or GCS or it
could be like if you're on Prem like
mini OSF Swift any of those so we we
definitely lack the like strict data
locality of like Hadoop like systems of
course we have a lot of like smart
caching to mitigate that but at the end
of the day you know what we're likely
not going to compete on terasort nor do
we want to but the the really kind of
like different processing paradigm that
we have is this incrementality like in
in those sorts of systems if you've
already processed a million images and
you want you add one more to your set we
kind of automatically handle that
incremental incremental processing which
is a huge savings as a pair as opposed
to like running re running things
manually without an awareness of what
data has changed so we'll have that be
the last question but we encourage
people to come up and talk to daniel as
well as to mingle a little bit longer we
have a space for maybe the next 50
minutes or so but we also want to give
people opportunity to to get out cuz it
is getting late so let's thank our
speaker again Daniel
[Applause]